This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。欢迎收听我的播客《百分之二》。在这个节目中，我将剖析我们在奇妙的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《百分之二》。名字就是数字2。欢迎收听《回首往事》播客。从1979年开始，这对我和来说是个重要时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首往事》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《知难而进》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身披盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《知难而进》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这段怀孕经历似乎是一个骗局。埃伦女士，你对这个特定的测试动了两次手脚，对吗？我动过一次手脚。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一名女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the podcast. the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《情网难逃》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《情网难逃》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客里，我们探讨一些二十岁时面临的生活重大改变和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today, we're tackling a topic that I think many of us are struggling with and maybe wouldn't even know. it and yet it really does impact a lot of our relationships in such insidious, often invisible ways. It is a very deep belief system and anxiety that can really disturb our ability to form meaningful connections, to love deeply and to trust others. And that is a fear of abandonment. I think all of us feel that instinctual drive to avoid emotionally pain. full experiences like being rejected or heartbroken or feeling forgotten about. And naturally, these events, the way people treat us or leave us is quite devastating. And it can leave some
大家好。欢迎回到这个节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里收听新的一期节目。今天，我们要探讨一个我认为我们许多人都在苦苦挣扎、甚至可能自己都不知道的话题，然而它确实以如此隐蔽、通常无形的方式深刻影响着我们的许多关系。这是一种非常深层的信念系统和焦虑，它会严重扰乱我们建立有意义的连接、深深地爱别人以及信任他人的能力。这就是被抛弃恐惧症。我认为我们所有人都有这种本能的驱动力，去逃避情感上的痛苦。像被拒绝、心碎或被遗忘这样充满痛苦的经历。自然地，这些事件、人们对待我们或离开我们的方式是相当具有毁灭性的。它会留下一些
very long-lasting emotional scars. But it's also somewhat part of life, right? We have to kind of come to peace with the reality that not every relationship is going to last, that people are going to leave, people are going to pass away. So there is no way of controlling how your relationships kind of pan out. But we can decide, A, how we want to treat ourselves, and be how we respond to these unfortunate kind of events. For some of us, though, we are so petrified of losing the ones we love or feeling abandoned that we really cannot allow ourselves to get close to to other people. And for many of us who are experiencing this, you know, it only comes from these experiences that we had in childhood or even early in our, you know, romantic relationships, right?
非常持久的情感伤痕。但这也是生活的一部分，对吧？我们必须在某种程度上接受这样一种现实：并非每段关系都能持久，人们终究会离开，人们终究会离世。所以没有办法控制你的关系会如何发展。但我们可以决定，第一，我们想如何对待自己，第二，我们如何应对这些不幸的事件。然而，对于我们中的一些人来说，我们对失去所爱之人或感到被抛弃感到无比恐惧，以至于我们真的无法让自己与他人亲近。对于我们许多经历过这一情况的人来说，你知道，它仅仅源于我们在童年甚至早期恋爱关系中经历过的这些事情，对吧？
When we were, you know, 18, 19, dating for the first time, where we developed almost an insecurity based on our experiences that everyone that we love will leave us. And this feeling can really influence how we approach not only our romantic connection. particularly the people we're dating or even married to, but also our interactions with people like friends, like family, like co-workers. There's a few ways that this manifest that we're going to speak about in this episode. I think if we have developed this really intense fear of being abandoned by those we love and what the emotional consequences of that would be, we can respond by becoming incredibly avoidant or self-sabotaging our relationship,
当我们处于，你知道的，18岁、19岁，第一次约会时，我们几乎根据自己的经验产生了一种不安全感，即我们所爱的人都会离开我们。这种感觉真的会影响我们处理罗曼蒂克关系的方式。尤其是我们正在约会甚至已经结婚的人，还有我们与朋友、家人、同事等人的互动。这种心态有几种表现形式，我们将在本期节目中讨论。我认为，如果我们对被所爱之人抛弃产生了这种非常强烈的恐惧，以及由此带来的情感后果，我们的反应可能是变得极其逃避，或者对我们的关系进行自我破坏，
becoming really emotionally numb to the world and to opportunities for love and intimacy and connection. But then on the flip side, a fear of abandonment is also really closely linked to things like intense people pleasing tendencies and clinginess and self-abandonment whereby we end up sacrificing our own needs for others because we think that that will keep them closer, that this will prevent our worst fears from being realized or confirming this really deep insecurity that we are correct. People we love cannot be trusted. We cannot trust them. They will inevitably leave us. And we know that that is not true. We know that there are so many people out there who stay in people's lives for decades. I feel like everyone has at least someone like that,
对世界、对爱、亲密关系和连接的机会变得情感麻木。但另一方面，对被抛弃的恐惧也与一些事情密切相关，比如强烈的讨好型人格倾向、黏人和自我抛弃，以至于我们最终为了别人而牺牲自己的需求，因为我们认为这样能把他们留在身边，这能防止我们最害怕的恐惧变成现实，或者证实我们内心深处的不安全感——我们是对的。我们所爱的人是不可信的。我们无法信任他们。他们不可避免地会离开我们。我们知道那不是真的。我们知道外面有那么多人在别人的生命中陪伴了几十年。我觉得每个人至少都有这样的人，
whether it is a parent or a friend or a family member or even a partner. So I really want to break down where this unfortunate, negative, but also false belief system comes from and how it's especially relevant for our 20s because I think it's often during this decade that we become a lot more aware of how our past and certain events or in some cases trauma continue to influence us or manifest in unhealthy relationship patterns. And that doesn't have to be our reality. Often we engage in a lot of self-blame for what are very deeply ingrained emotional reactions that have emerged from a lot of things that were beyond our control. You know, we wonder why we can never let people get close, or we always feel the need to start a fight or sabotage our relationships when they begin to feel
无论是父母、朋友、家庭成员还是伴侣。所以我真的很想剖析这种不幸的、消极的但同时又是虚假的信念系统究竟从何而来，以及为什么它与我们的二十岁尤为相关，因为我认为正是在这个十年里，我们开始更加意识到自己的过去以及某些事件，或者在某些情况下，创伤如何继续影响我们或表现为不健康的关系模式。而这并不是我们必然的现实。通常，我们将许多深植于内心、源于许多超出我们控制的事情的情感反应归咎于自己。你知道，我们纳闷为什么自己从不让人走近，或者为什么总觉得当关系开始变得
too comfortable. So I really also want to provide an explanation. for why that is. You know, sometimes it's really subtle things or sometimes it's big things like witnessing a divorce or having BPD, early romantic experiences, but also I think it's important that we acknowledge this anxiety where it comes from and how to integrate it, how to manage it. It is something that we can all definitely heal from. So there is so much to discuss if you are someone who has been struggling with this and you're trying to find a reason why you're, you're, find it so hard to trust others and connect with them, hopefully this episode provides you with an explanation with some answers with somewhere to go. So without further ado, let's get into it.
过于舒适时，自己就需要挑起争端或破坏关系。所以我真的还想提供一个解释。说明为什么会这样。你知道，有时是非常微小的事情，有时是重大事情，比如目睹父母离异、患有边缘型人格障碍、早期的恋爱经历，但我也认为同样重要的是，我们要承认这种焦虑的来源以及如何整合它、如何管理它。这绝对是我们所有人都能从中治愈的事情。所以有很多内容要讨论，如果你一直饱受这个问题的困扰，并且正试图找出为什么自己会觉得如此难以信任他人并与他们建立联系，希望这期节目能为你提供一个解释、一些答案以及一个解决的方向。废话不多说，我们切入正题吧。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
百分之二。这是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《百分之二》中。我将剖析我们在奇妙的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，穿透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题其实都是压力的结果。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out, on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《百分之二》。拼写是T-W-O-P-e-r-s-e-n-t。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别招惹乡下女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也千万别招惹她的朋友。
We always say that trust your. Girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care.
我们总是说要相信你的。女朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《女朋友们》的全新季中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都跟同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。
So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the Girlfriends. Trust me, babe. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓。我要成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。
Remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打莉儿·金的胸部吗？或者当说坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟莉儿·金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《回首往事》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about Christ. crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因危机。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备聊聊80年代的可卡因，只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the I-Heartman. radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, learn the hard way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of
是的。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回首往事》。欢迎收听我的新播客《知难而进》，我是主持人、你喜爱的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝
Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're saying, we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you
心理健康意识月，我将结合我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某样东西时，我们全情投入于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们却在说，我们仍在追逐它，而且我们不知道什么时候才算做够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯廷·罗斯，因为你觉得在
hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app.
人世间做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两个不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹只是因为想做一个好人。加入我的新播客《知难而进》，和基尔·盖恩斯一起就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用。
Search Learn the hard way and listen now. Okay, so first of all, as we do, we need to get our basics down, Pat, before we jump into the theories and ideas that make up a fear of abandonment. I think typical of psychology terms that gain very general societal notoriety and popularity, sometimes the truth about ideas like a fear of abandonment can become misconstrued. and leading to people becoming also somewhat misinformed or at times confused or excluded from a definition or from a narrative around a certain issue. And that's really not ideal because I think there are so many of us, especially in our 20s, as we enter into our first really serious long-term relationships or where we start to encounter things like death for a lot of us or friendship groups falling apart.
搜索《知难而进》并立即收听。好的，首先，老规矩，在深入探讨构成被抛弃恐惧症的各种理论和观点之前，我们需要先把基础知识彻底搞清楚。我认为，对于那些在社会上获得广泛知名度和流行度的心理学术语来说，有时关于诸如被抛弃恐惧症等观念的真相可能会被曲解。导致人们也变得有些误解，或者有时感到困惑，或者被排除在围绕某个议题的定义或叙事之外。这真的不太理想，因为我认为我们中的许多人，尤其是在我们二十岁的时候，当我们开始进入真正严肃的长期恋爱关系，或者对我们中的许多人来说，开始遭遇诸如死亡或朋友圈破裂之类的事情时，
often what we do is we question some of our past experiences. We are undergoing this very real emotional battle at times between our primary instinct for love and security and a much deeper fear of being hurt or discarded by someone we feel really connected to. So firstly, it's important to note that a fear of abandonment, it's not a recognized mental health condition. You know, your doctor, unfortunately, is not going to be able to give you a diagnosis and a cure and send you on your way because it's a lot more nuance than that. Instead, psychology has kind of come to see this as a type of anxiety in which we feel this overwhelming yet often unwanted and unwarranted, fear that the people we love will leave us. And so we react in somewhat irrational ways,
通常我们所做的是质疑我们过去的一些经历。有时，我们在对爱的基本渴望和安全感与对被自己真正产生连接的人伤害或抛弃的更深恐惧之间，经历着非常真实的情感斗争。因此，首先，重要的是要注意到，被抛弃恐惧症并不是一种被承认的精神健康状况。你知道，不幸的是，你的医生无法为你提供诊断和治疗方案然后打发你走，因为它要微妙得多。相反，心理学已经将这种现象视为一种焦虑症，在这种焦虑中，我们感到一种压倒性的、但往往是不必要的和毫无根据的恐惧，即我们所爱的人会离开我们。因此，我们以某种不理智的方式做出反应，
perhaps sabotaging our relationships, pulling away so that people don't have the chance to hurt us, or feeling a really intense need to be close to people at all times, perhaps sometimes also transforming into codependency. Actually, the thing is that a fear of abandonment, although it's not a recognized mental health condition. It's really, really closely linked to a bunch of other concepts that we have discussed on the show. Things like emotional unavailability and hyper-independence, even a social phobia, but it differs in that its primary function on an emotional level, the primary function of this fear of abandonment,
也许是破坏我们的关系，抽离自己以便人们没有机会伤害我们，或者感到一种非常强烈地想要时刻与他人保持亲密的需要，有时甚至会演变成共同依赖。事实上，被抛弃恐惧症虽然不是一种被承认的精神健康状况，但它与我们在节目中讨论过的一系列其他概念有着非常非常紧密的联系。比如情感不可接近、过度独立，甚至是社交恐惧症，但它的不同之处在于，它在情感层面的主要功能——被抛弃恐惧症的主要功能，
is to help us avoid the pain of being rejected, dismissed or let down. And it's not so much a fear of general social interaction or even intimacy, but a fear of what will happen when these things we deeply value are taken away. What is going to occur in their absence? Another distinction is that this fear of abandonment, it shows up in all of our relationships, not just our romantic ones. I think we typically think about abandonment issues when it comes to dating. But people will experience this type of anxiety and worry for their friendships as well. They'll worry that their friends will leave them. They worry about what will happen if their family members, something happens to their family members or even
是帮助我们逃避被拒绝、被冷落或被辜负的痛苦。它与其说是对一般社交互动或亲密关系的恐惧，不如说是对当我们这些深感珍视的东西被夺走时会发生什么的恐惧。在它们缺席的情况下会发生什么？另一个区别是，这种被抛弃恐惧症会出现在我们所有的关系中，而不仅仅是恋爱关系。我认为我们在谈到被抛弃问题时，通常会想到约会。但人们在友情中也会经历这种类型的焦虑和担忧。他们会担心朋友会离开他们。他们担心如果自己的家庭成员遭遇不测会发生什么，甚至
co-workers or acquaintances or being rejected or abandoned by entire social circles, which we know was quite irrational. But I would say the reason that we think about it a lot in terms of romantic connections is because for many of us, these fears of being abandoned aren't really fully realized until we enter into our first or second romantic relationship. That's because I think unlike friendships or family, romantic relationships really take on this whole new level of emotional closeness and expected intimacy and vulnerability. The stakes are a lot higher. The risk of being hurt really increases with each kind of moment and memory where you get closer, typically also because we often have more than one friend or more than one family member, but we only have one partner.
担心被同事、熟人拒绝或抛弃，或者被整个社交圈抛弃，我们知道这相当不理智。但我可以说，我们之所以在恋爱关系方面经常考虑到这一点，是因为对我们许多人来说，这些被抛弃的恐惧直到我们进入第一段或第二段恋爱关系时才真正完全显现出来。这是因为我认为，不同于友情或家庭，恋爱关系真正呈现出一种全新的情感亲密水平、期望的亲密感和脆弱感。赌注要高得多。随着你变得越来越亲密的每一个时刻和记忆，受伤害的风险确实在增加，通常也是因为我们往往有不止一个朋友或不止一个家庭成员，但我们只有一个伴侣。
And we are often naturally, incredibly bonded to the people who fill this role in our life. And so I think everyone is going to experience this fear on some level that one day they may find this person they love drifting away or outright, you know, leaving them having to mend a broken heart. And as humans, like I mentioned before, one of our primary instinctual drives is to avoid pain. And often we think of that selectively to just mean physical pain or injury. but we know from countless, countless studies that certain emotional experiences can also manifest in the body. And it's a concept known as psychogenic pain whereby when we are exposed to psychological distress or emotional distress, that can actually manifest in very real physical discomfort and suffering. So I think that reason is why a lot of us do relate to having. a heightened anxiety over the possibility of being abandoned or left by someone. And I think if you
而且我们往往自然而然地与在我们的生活中扮演这个角色的人紧密相连。所以我认为每个人都在某种程度上体验过这种恐惧，即有一天他们可能会发现自己爱的人渐行渐远，或者干脆离开他们，让他们不得不去修补破碎的心。作为人类，就像我之前提到的，我们最基本的本能驱动力之一就是逃避痛苦。通常我们会有选择地认为这仅仅意味着身体上的痛苦或受伤。但我们从无数的研究中得知，某些情感体验也能在身体上表现出来。这是一个被称为心因性疼痛的概念，即当我们暴露于心理困扰或情感困扰时，它实际上可以在身体上表现为非常真实的不适和痛苦。所以我认为这就是为什么我们很多人都觉得自己有
don't have that anxiety at times, if you're someone who, you know, kind of approaches your relationships, like everyone is replaceable, no one can ever hurt me, that is equally as unhealthy. I also want to say that this reaction, especially when it gets to a really intense fear of abandonment, it is neither intentional nor is it voluntary. It is not an opt-in situation. No one is looking to experience more anxiety than they already are. But also it almost consistently emerges from situations that are outside of our control that have influenced us on a somewhat unconscious level and then begin to manifest in certain behaviors and tendencies that really interrupt our ability to connect. People with abandonment issues fears whatever we want to call them they're not going to
对被某人抛弃或丢下的可能性产生高度焦虑的共鸣。而且我认为如果你有时没有那种焦虑，如果你是一个……你知道的，对待关系的态度像是“每个人都是可替代的，没有人能伤害我”这样的人，那是同样不健康的。我还想说，这种反应，尤其是当它演变成对被抛弃的强烈恐惧时，既不是故意的，也不是自愿的。这不是一种可以随心所欲选择的情况。没有人会主动去经历比现在更多的焦虑。而且它几乎总是源于超出我们控制的情况，这些情况在某种程度上在无意识的层面影响了我们，然后开始表现为某些真正打断我们连接能力的特定行为和倾向。有被抛弃问题、恐惧症或其他什么问题的人，他们不会
experience that in the same way it's not always going to be identical so there are actually four different types of profiles or archetypes of people who are experiencing abandonment wounds or who are fearful of abandonment so there's the saboteur the needy the avoidant and the serial data and sometimes all of these can operate within one person but let's break them down one by one so the saboteur is someone who undermines their own relationships to try and identify faults and push people away before they get hurt. Often, when that happens, they'll blame the other person, they'll blame their friends or their string of partners. They'll say that they're toxic or problematic.
以完全相同的方式经历它，它并不总是千篇一律的。所以实际上有四种不同类型的人格画像或原型，用来形容那些经历过被抛弃创伤或对被抛弃感到恐惧的人：破坏者、黏人精、逃避者和连续约会者。有时所有这些特征都可以在同一个人身上运作。让我们逐一剖析。破坏者是那种会暗中破坏自己的关系，试图挑出毛病，并在自己受伤之前把人推开的人。通常，当这种情况发生时，他们会责怪对方，责怪他们的朋友或一连串的伴侣。他们会说对方有毒或有问题。
Rather than really closely examining what this pattern of behavior says about their own emotional wounds, right? that they're actually sabotaging these relationships, perhaps subconsciously, because that way these people can never leave them if they leave first. So the next is the needy or the clingy. And this is someone who often displays behavior that is very similar to someone in the early stages of codependency, right? So getting close to someone incredibly quickly, perhaps sharing too many intimate details about themselves too soon, or really wanting to reach certain master.
而不是去仔细审视这种行为模式反映了他们自己的什么情感创伤，对吧？即他们实际上在破坏这些关系，也许是潜意识里的，因为如果他们先离开，这些人就永远无法抛弃他们。接下来是黏人精。这类人通常表现出与处于共同依赖早期阶段的人非常相似的行为，对吧？比如非常快地与某人走得太近，可能过早地分享关于自己的太多私密细节，或者非常渴望达成某些目标。
like exclusivity or applying labels really early on. And they do this in hopes of kind of fast-tracking a relationship to provide them with a sense of security before they truly do actually start to trust this person. It's kind of like the false pretense of, okay, well, if we have this label, if they have reassured me that we're exclusive, if they're not sleeping with other people, they're not going to leave me. And this will provide me kind of with the structure in which I can actually start to build a relationship with this person after they've already provided me the reassurance that we are in that point. The next is the avoidant and the avoidant will almost abstain particularly from intimate vulnerable relationships or close friendships entirely.
比如排他性，或者很早就贴上标签。他们这样做是希望能通过快车道建立一段关系，在他们真正开始信任这个人之前，为他们提供一种安全感。这有点像是一种虚假的借口，即“好吧，如果我们有了这个标签，如果他们向我保证我们是排他的，如果他们没有跟别人上床，他们就不会离开我”。这将为我提供某种结构，在这之后我才能真正开始与这个人建立关系，此前他们已经向我提供了我们处于那种状态的安心保证。接下来是逃避者，逃避者几乎会完全避免亲密的、脆弱的关系或亲密的友情。
They may pull away from family members or certain social circles because they are so fearful of being hurt or disappointed. If they pull away first much like the saboteur, then they will have have the power and agency. That's kind of what they're telling themselves. Basically, they're saying, what, you know, very similar to the saboteur, I cannot be abandoned if I make the decision first. Therefore, although it's going to leave me in the same position of not having these people around or feeling lonely, at least I'm in control here. At least I'm not going to be surprised. And finally, we have the serial data. Also similar to the saboteur, this person will, cycle through relationships, friendships, quite quickly, but they'll find themselves not really
他们可能会疏远家庭成员或某些社交圈，因为他们太害怕受到伤害或失望。如果他们像破坏者一样率先抽离，那么他们就会拥有权力和自主权。这正是他们内心的自我暗示。基本上，他们是在说，你知道的，这与破坏者非常相似，“如果我先做出决定，我就不会被抛弃。因此，虽然这会让我陷入没有这些人陪伴或感到孤独的同样境地，但至少在这里我是掌控一切的。至少我不会感到惊讶。”最后，我们有连续约会者。同样类似于破坏者，这个人会相当快地在关系和友情之间循环往复，但他们会发现自己并没有真正
getting attached in the same way that the saboteur does. Instead, what they're really choosing to do is soothe their abandonment wound with new people, right? So they might fall in love pretty quickly. The relationship ends perhaps because of sabotage, perhaps because of something else. and instead of really acknowledging that that really hurts, instead of acknowledging that perhaps this is really unfortunate and really deeply painful, they will find someone else to heal them rather than really acknowledging why they find this so particularly distressing. So I would say that something that's really important is that none of these types of individuals associated with abandonment issues are bad people. It's really important.
以破坏者那种方式产生依附。相反，他们真正选择做的是用新的人来抚慰他们的被抛弃创伤，对吧？所以他们可能会坠入爱河相当快。这段关系结束了，也许是因为破坏，也许是因为其他原因。他们没有真正承认这真的很伤人，没有承认这可能是不幸的且极其痛苦的，而是会去找另一个人来治愈自己，而不是去真正承认为什么他们会觉得这特别令人痛苦。所以我想说，非常重要的一点是，所有这些与被抛弃问题相关的个体类型都不是坏人。这一点非常重要。
to remember that there should be really no shame in admitting that perhaps, you know, you have historically approached relationships like this or that this is how you continue to approach relationships because I would say A, so much of why you are this person is out of our control, which we'll discuss in a second. But B, I think if you're afraid to correctly identify ways in which your actions are perhaps maladaptive, you'll actually just prolong these experiences and it's not going to lead to any changes. Outside of these very high-level archetypes, there are some other core behaviours that I just want to quickly dive into a little bit deeper. So we spoke about cycling through relationships. Some of us who are facing a fear of abandonment
要记住，承认过去你可能曾以这种方式对待关系，或者你将继续以这种方式对待关系，真的不应该感到羞耻。因为我想说，第一，你为什么会成为这样的人，很大程度上超出了我们的控制范围，我们一会儿会讨论；第二，如果你害怕正确识别你的行为可能是不适应的方面，你实际上只会延长这些经历，而这不会带来任何改变。除了这些高层面的原型之外，还有一些我想快速深入探讨的核心行为。所以我们谈到了循环往复于不同的关系中。我们中一些面临被抛弃恐惧的人，
may want to engage in numerous, consistent, shallow relationships. We're afraid to ever let someone truly see the ugly, vulnerable, scared side of us. So we pretend. this part of us. We never let anyone see that because if they do leave us, we can always comfort ourselves with the knowledge that this person really never really knew us that deeply. So that is very similar to a fear of intimacy. And often the reason we cycle through relationships, particularly shallow ones, is because we find a reason to leave them before the other person can leave us. We talked about sabotaging relationships, but there's this other interesting term called emotional baiting. So this is where we attempt to create situations that elicit a particular emotional
可能会想要参与大量、持续、肤浅的关系。我们害怕让任何人真正看到我们丑陋、脆弱、害怕的一面。所以我们伪装。这部分自己。我们从不让任何人看到，因为如果他们真的抛弃了我们，我们总是可以用这样一种认知来安慰自己：这个人其实从来没有真正深入地了解过我们。这与对亲密关系的恐惧非常相似。通常，我们循环往复于各种关系、尤其是肤浅关系的原因是，我们在对方抛弃我们之前找到了离开的理由。我们讨论了破坏关系，但还有另一个有趣的术语叫做“情感诱导”。这就是我们试图制造能够引发伴侣特定情感反应的情况，
reaction from a partner, either positive or negative. So in psychology, emotional baiting is actually used to describe certain narcissistic tendencies that are inherently very manipulative and attention seeking. But in this case, that is not accurate, right? That is not why people are baiting their partners or baiting someone in their life. This behavior actually represents something a lot more vulnerable. It reveals a part of us that really needs love. So what we're doing when we emotionally bait people in our lives, you know, by starting fights, by withdrawing, by saying things we don't mean, is we're really testing them to see if they will leave us. So for people with a fear of abandonment, this is a slightly counterintuitive way of building trust.
无论是积极的还是消极的。所以在心理学中，情感诱导实际上被用来描述某些本质上具有高度操纵性和寻求关注倾向的自恋倾向。但在这种情况下，这是不准确的，对吧？人们诱导伴侣或生活中的某人并不是出于这个原因。这种行为实际上代表了更脆弱的东西。它揭示了我们内心深处真正需要爱的一部分。所以我们在生活中对他人进行情感诱导时，通过挑起争端、抽离、说言不由衷的话，实际上是在测试他们是否会抛弃我们。因此，对于有被抛弃恐惧的人来说，这是一种略显反直觉的建立信任的方式。
it's interesting because in these moments we're not trying to endanger our relationship, right? It's not all about self-sabotage. In fact, I think these behaviors are almost a sign of how much we want these relationships to last. Hence, why we're really subconsciously testing them to see if the other person is genuine and if they will stay and if what they're saying is true. We really want to entrench ourselves further and feel that deeper level of vulnerability. and intimacy, but before we can do that, we need to be like a hundred percent sure that this is not going to end badly, that this person is not going to withdraw from us. So we kind of become our worst selves to test them, to really push them and then closely watch their response. The next thing is clinging to unhealthy relationships. Some people with abandonment issues,
有趣的是，在这些时刻，我们并不是在试图危害我们的关系，对吧？这并不完全是关于自我破坏。事实上，我认为这些行为几乎表明了我们是多么希望这些关系能够持久。因此，我们才会在潜意识里测试他们，看对方是否真诚，看他们是否会留下来，看他们所说的是否属实。我们真的想让自己更深地融入其中，体验更深层次的脆弱感。和亲密感，但在我们做到这一点之前，我们需要百分之百确信这不会以糟糕的结局收场，这个人才不会从我们身边抽离。所以我们有点表现得像我们最糟糕的自己来测试他们，真正去逼迫他们，然后密切观察他们的反应。接下来是死死抓住不健康的关系不放。有些有被抛弃问题的人，
there's been research to show that they might stay in relationships, that aren't good for them, even when they have a desire to leave. I think that's because the fear of being alone is a lot more powerful. And they often perceive it to be safer, to pursue someone who cannot provide them the emotional connection that they need, because instinctually they know that they'll never get too close. I would say that this is actually really, it's kind of a way that our brain or our fear of abandonment tricks us,
研究表明，他们可能会留在对他们没有好处的关系中，即使他们心里有离开的愿望。我认为这是因为孤独的恐惧要强大得多。而且他们通常认为，追求一个无法提供他们所需情感连接的人会更安全，因为他们凭本能知道自己永远不会靠得太近。我想说，这其实真的……这有点像我们的大脑或我们对被抛弃的恐惧愚弄了我们的方式，
because we know based on principles of attachment and familiarity, and proximity, that the more time we spend with someone, even if we are trying our hardest, the more bonded we will become. So it's actually quite dangerous, I think, to pursue relationships with people you think won't hurt you in order to protect yourself because that might actually really backfire and further entrench your fear around abandonment. Finally, we have needing constant reassurance. This is what I've experienced a lot, especially in my current relationship. And, you know, My partner is incredible. He is beautiful.
因为根据依恋、熟悉和邻近的原则，我们知道，我们和一个人花的时间越多，即使我们已经尽了最大努力，我们的羁绊就会越深。所以，为了保护自己而刻意去追求那些你认为不会伤害你的人，实际上是相当危险的，我认为这可能会适得其反，并进一步加深你对被抛弃的恐惧。最后，我们需要不断的安心保证。这是我经历过很多次的，尤其是在我目前的恋爱关系中。而且，你知道，我的伴侣非常棒。他很优秀。
But no matter how much I think love and attention you give someone, especially someone who's maybe had past experiences where they've been let down, you kind of always have this fear that they're lying to you or that they're going to change their mind. So you really consistently, regularly require them to confirm and reassure you that they're not going anywhere, that yes, they still love you. No, they're not annoyed. They're not mad at you. they're not going to leave you.
但无论你给予某人多少爱和关注，尤其是那些可能有过被辜负经历的人，你总是会有一种恐惧：他们在对你撒谎，或者他们会改变主意。所以你确实需要他们持续地、定期地向你确认和保证，他们不会离开，是的，他们依然爱你。不，他们没有觉得被打扰。他们没有生你的气。他们不会离开你。
It kind of also can sometimes result in what we call forning behavior, right? So that's also really closely related to people pleasing tendencies where when we fawn, when we try and please someone, what we're doing is constantly trying to make this person happy sometimes at our own expense by being really excessively generous, affectionate, or passive, or agreeable, as to not give them a reason to leave us. and that can often result in us actually neglecting our own needs or becoming really hypersensitive to things like conflict or criticisms, small disagreements that are really natural in any relationship, but we see them as a threat because they undermine our sense of security.
这有时有时也会导致我们所说的“讨好行为”，对吧？所以这也是与讨好型人格倾向密切相关的，当我们讨好时，当我们试图取悦某人时，我们所做的是不断试图让这个人开心，有时甚至是以牺牲我们自己的需求为代价，表现得过度慷慨、充满爱心、被动或随和，以免给他们留下离开我们的理由。而这通常会导致我们实际上忽视了自己的需求，或者对冲突、批评、任何关系中都很自然的微小分歧变得高度敏感，但我们却将它们视为威胁，因为它们破坏了我们的安全感。
Small things like that, if you are someone who has previously been in relationships where people have given and taken love very inconsistently or you've been raised with very inconsistent parents, Small things like arguments, like little disagreements, they trigger an alarm in our brain, one that has a very low threshold. Because we have become hypervigilant towards anything that may indicate that the other person has a reason to disappear. That is why we need that reassurance. That is why we may become quite passive because we want to keep the peace.
诸如此类的小事，如果你以前经历过伴侣前后矛盾地给予和收回爱，或者你的父母前后很不一致，小事情，比如争吵、小分歧，都会在我们的大脑中拉响警报，一个阈值非常低的警报。因为我们已经变得对任何可能表明对方有理由消失的迹象高度警惕。这就是为什么我们需要那种安心保证。这就是为什么我们可能会变得相当被动，因为我们想要维持和平。
We really want to make sure that they have no reason to need to walk away. And if they do, that would be our fault. One thing that's really interesting to me is how some of these behaviors that are very deeply associated with a fear of abandonment have become kind of romanticized in society, especially around pop culture and places like TikTok or Instagram. Particularly what we're seeing is this like idolization of a very avoidant, detached approach to romantic connection. So trends around being heartless or how to stay detached and cold. in the early stages of a relationship, how to get people obsessed with you, to appear emotionless and untouchable, you know, the heartless one in particular really, really worries me. Because when we examine that deeper, I don't actually think that having no emotion towards people
我们真的想确保他们没有任何理由想要走开。如果他们真的走了，那将是我们的错。有一件事让我觉得非常有趣，那就是那些与被抛弃恐惧症深度关联的行为，是如何在社会中被浪漫化的，尤其是在流行文化以及诸如TikTok或Instagram等平台上。我们特别看到的是，人们对罗曼蒂克关系中那种高度回避、抽离的态度进行了偶像化。因此，关于在关系初期如何做到无心或是如何保持抽离和冷漠的趋势非常流行，如何让别人对你着迷，表现得毫无情绪且不可触碰，特别是那种“无心之人”，真的、真的很让我担心。因为当我们深入审视这一点时，我不认为对人完全没有情绪是一件特别健康的事情。它在某种程度上，也是被抛弃恐惧症的薄弱伪装。我认为如果你经历过被狠狠抛弃、心碎欲绝，或者被某人深深伤害和背叛的经历，我们就会走向完全相反的极端。并且我们喜欢表现得毫无情绪，或者在某种程度上让自己相信这就是我们可以成为的人，而实际上这表现出来的是我们对被抛弃的恐惧。在潜意识里，我们的大脑想要避免再次发生那种情况。所以它们吸收了这段经历，并扭转了所有可能让你陷入先前境地的行为。让你表现得有所不同。
at all is a particularly healthy thing. It also, in some ways, is very thinly veiled abandonment issues. I think that if you've been through an experience where you've been left really, like, absolutely demolished and heartbroken or just so hurt and betrayed by someone, we kind of go the complete opposite way. And we like to appear emotionless or in some ways convince ourselves that this is a person we can be when really what it is manifesting is our fear of abandonment. Subconsciously, our minds want to avoid another situation like that. So they take the experience and they reverse all of the behaviors that perhaps put you in that previous situation. so that you act differently.
有时你的行为方式与你的愿望甚至你的整体健康状况背道而驰。这真正联系到了被抛弃恐惧症的来源，这也是我接下来想要讨论的。所以一般来说，心理学家将对被抛弃的恐惧归因于我们在童年时期内化的经历和信念。作为一个孩子，如果你被剥夺了真正基本的、核心的安慰，比如身体上的抚慰、情感连接和安全感，我们在成年后就会学会不去相信这些东西的持久性。
And sometimes you act in a way that's really counter to your desires or even your overall well-being. This really links to where a fear of abandonment comes from, which is what I want to discuss next. So generally, psychologists attribute a fear of abandonment to the experiences and beliefs that we have internalized as children. So as a child, if you are denied really basic fundamental comforts like physical affection, emotional connection and safety, we learn not to trust the permanence of these things in adulthood.
而这带来的结果就是一种功能失调且不安全的依恋风格。在这种情况下，通常是逃避型或焦虑型的依恋风格。我们担心。人们会收回他们的爱，所以我们变得极其压力重重和恐慌，要么把他们拉近并死死抓住不放，要么自己先彻底抽离。
And what that results in is a very dysfunctional and insecure attachment style. In this case, often it's an avoidant or anxious attachment style. We're worried. People will withdraw their love, so we become extremely stressed and panicked, either drawing them in and really wanting to hold on to them or completely removing ourselves first.
这导致了一种高度失调且不安全的人际依恋模式。在这种情况下，通常是回避型或焦虑型的依恋模式。我们会感到担忧，担心别人会收回他们的爱，因此我们变得极其焦虑和恐慌，要么把他们拉近、紧紧抓住不放，要么率先彻底疏远对方。
traumatic events in childhood as well can really disrupt this sense that our relationships with people will be sustained even if there's distance. That is something that a child has to learn. It's called object constancy. Basically what that means is that even if your parent leaves you a daycare or leaves you at school for the afternoon, they are A going to come back and be the relationship is going to be the same. But, you know, events like a divorce or injury or the death of a parent or a caregiver, they're really significant and they really disrupt the development of this really fundamental cognition. So although we know that this person didn't intentionally leave us or mean to hurt us, we still really feel the intensity of their absence.
童年时期的创伤事件也会严重破坏这样一种观念：即我们与他人的关系即使相隔远方也能维持下去。这是孩子必须学会的一点。这被称为客体恒常性。基本上，这意味着即使你的父母把你放在日托中心或学校过一个下午，他们A会回来，而且B你们的关系会保持不变。但是，你知道，像离婚、受伤、父母或照顾者的离世这样的事件，它们真的非常重大，并且会严重破坏这种非常基础的认知的发育。因此，尽管我们知道这个人并非故意离开我们，也并非有意伤害我们，但我们依然能强烈感受到他们缺席带来的痛苦。
And we rationalize that if we just been a lot less closer to them, if we had loved them less, we would be in less pain. And so the logic follows that to avoid future pain, avoid future connection. So that's one of the origins because, as we know, healthy human development really requires those physical and emotional needs being met. And during childhood, that often comes from our parents. But during adulthood, it can come from a broader range of personal and romantic relationships. I say this all the time, but something that I think psychology as a field really needs to
我们会进行合理化解释，认为如果我们当初和他们不那么亲近，如果我们少爱他们一些，我们受到的痛苦就会少一些。于是逻辑推论就是：为了避免未来的痛苦，就要避免未来的连接。所以这就是根源之一，因为正如我们所知，健康的人类发展确实需要满足这些身体和情感需求。而在童年时期，这通常来自我们的父母。但在成年时期，它可以来自更广泛的个人和浪漫关系。我一直在说这话，但我认为心理学作为一个领域真正需要
investigate more is the impact of early romantic experiences on later romantic and emotional well-being and also dating. Specifically, how do we go on to form healthy relationships and seek out the right people based on what we were kind of taught that love was? I think often the research on attachment style really only goes one way. But I also think that it's really important to acknowledge that, you know, although maybe your first relationship was when you were young, maybe 17, 18, even younger, that's still going to have a really, really foundational impact. That is because, as these cognitive scientists at MIT have explained, we experience peak mental processing and memory power at around 18 to 19.
去更多研究的一个课题，是早期恋爱经历对后来的恋爱、情感健康以及约会的影响。具体来说，根据我们被灌输的关于爱的定义，我们接下来该如何建立健康的关系并寻找对的人？我认为，关于依恋类型的研究往往只朝着一个方向发展。但我也认为，非常重要的一点是我们要承认，也许你的第一段恋爱发生在你很年轻的时候，比如17、18岁甚至更小，但这仍然会产生非常非常根本的影响。这是因为，正如麻省理工学院的这些认知科学家所解释的那样，我们在18到19岁左右会经历达到顶峰的心智处理能力和记忆力。
And that kind of tapers off the older we get. But it is around that time, I'm going to say like a bracket of 17 to 21, that we experience a lot of first, you know, our first love, our first breakup, our first kiss. And that's all occurring during a period where we are still developing, but also absorbing information and memories at a crazy pace. So for some people, a particularly painful relationship, perhaps you dated someone who cheated on you or treated you poorly or lied or left suddenly. That is going to be a core experience that makes you really fearful of situations that could recreate that pain in the future.
随着我们年龄的增长，这种能力会逐渐减弱。但正是在那个时期，我姑且称之为17岁到21岁的年龄段，我们会经历许多“第一次”，你知道的，我们的初恋、初次分手、初吻。而这一切都发生在这样一个时期：我们仍在成长中，却同时又以疯狂的速度吸收着信息和记忆。因此，对某些人来说，一段极其痛苦的恋爱经历——也许你曾与一个欺骗你、对你不好、撒谎或突然离开的人交往过——将成为一段核心经历，让你对未来可能重现这种痛苦的情境感到极度恐惧。
And from that we see abandonment issues being born, and they're really maintained by that cycle we spoke about before of hypervigilance, of self-sabotage, of avoidance. Abandonment issues can also stem from a really intense fear of loneliness, but also it's quite closely linked to borderline personality disorder. Now, this podcast is not a place for self-diagnosing mental health conditions. So I just want to make that really, really clear, but I think that we cannot talk about abandonment issues without talking about BPD because they are so closely aligned in a lot of people's minds. So BPD, if you haven't heard about it before, it's a mental health disorder
由此，我们看到了被抛弃情结的诞生，而它们之所以能持续存在，正是靠着我们之前谈到的那个循环：过度警觉、自我破坏、回避。被抛弃情结也可能源于对孤独的极度恐惧，而且它与边缘型人格障碍（BPD）紧密相连。现在，这个播客可不是自我诊断心理健康状况的地方。所以我只是想把这一点说得非常非常清楚，但我认为我们在探讨被抛弃情结时，绝不能不提及边缘型人格障碍（BPD），因为在许多人的心中，它们是如此紧密相连。所以BPD，如果你以前没听说过的话，它是一种心理健康障碍，
characterised by a lot of symptoms, mainly really chronic challenges with maintaining healthy relationships, feelings of low self-worth, impulsivity, really volatile moods. This disorder is often really hallmarked by a pattern of very unstable personal relationships. relationships. And what that means is that a fear of abandonment is also often a really big part of the lives of those who are impacted by BPD. It's also really one of the most common symptoms that we will see. There's really no kind of solid explanation that can be given as to why this is. But according to a number of psychologists and psychiatrists, the fear of being abandoned often causes people with BPD to form unhealthy attachments. Sometimes they can abruptly cut off these relationships,
其特征有许多症状，主要是维持健康关系时面临的长期挑战、低自我价值感、冲动以及极其反复无常的情绪。这种障碍通常以极不稳定的个人关系模式为标志。这意味着，对被抛弃的恐惧往往也是受BPD影响的人的生活中一个非常重大的部分。这也是我们将看到的最常见的症状之一。对于为什么会这样，其实并没有给出什么坚实的解释。但根据一些心理学家和精神病学家的说法，被抛弃的恐惧往往会导致患有BPD的人建立不健康的依恋关系。有时他们会突然切断这些关系，
effectively abandoning their partners, and other times they make really frantic attempts to hold onto the relationship. And it's this overly, I think it's quite intense or erratic behavior. That is what causes them to push loved ones away, makes it harder to have those stable relationships like we talked about, but also heightens that fear around abandonment, because there is a cycle of perhaps very difficult interpersonal connections, interactions, and experiences. Not everyone with abandonment issues, though, has BPD. Let's really make sure that's quite clear.
实际上抛弃了他们的伴侣，而另一些时候，他们则会拼命试图抓住这段关系。正是这种过度激烈或反复无常的行为，导致他们把所爱的人推开，让他们更难拥有我们之前谈论过的那种稳定关系，同时也加剧了对被抛弃的恐惧，因为可能存在一个充满艰难的人际连接、互动和经历的循环。然而，并非所有有被抛弃情结的人都患有BPD。让我们务必把这一点弄清楚。
BPD is a separate condition that just has some overlap with this unique type of anxiety. And like we said before, fearing abandonment, it's going to show up very differently. It's going to come from very different experiences. But what I want to talk about is what is kind of the long. long-term prognosis here. And how can we push past our fear of being rejected or disappointed or abandoned? How can we kind of break out of our self-sabotaging patterns or our avoidant behaviors to really trust and to really love people? So we're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break.
BPD是一个独立的病症，只是与这种独特的焦虑有一些重叠。正如我们之前所说，害怕被抛弃的表现会非常不同，它源于非常不同的经历。但我想讨论的是，这里的长期预后究竟如何？我们该如何摆脱对被拒绝、被失望或被抛弃的恐惧？我们又该如何打破自我破坏的模式或回避行为，去真正信任和爱一个人？因此，在短暂的休息之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等人进行对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油天生具有炎症性。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends.
我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。名字是T-W-O-P-e-r-s-e-n-t，可在I-Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。每个男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，绝对不要惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也绝对不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的女友们。
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《女友们》的这个新季中：天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们竟然都和同一个多产的骗子约会过。我觉得自己就像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们决定亲自动手。我说，哦，见鬼，绝不。我发誓。我要成为他的最后一个目标。
He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
他会得到他应得的下场。收听《女友们》。相信我，宝贝。可在I-heart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克（Sam Jay）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。在每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
畅谈80年代的快克。需要说明的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅是因为快克。我随时准备在节目里聊快克，但只是想让你们知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，这是我们第二集讨论快克了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black. black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, We get so wrapped up in the chase
我认为没有哪一年比对黑人来说更重要了。
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
黑人。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Game. is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now.
我们太沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，却仍然在继续追逐，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），是因为你觉得在人间时做一个好人很重要吗？
I think a lot of us are struggling with this in very invisible ways, often because I really don't think we want to admit this very vulnerable insecurity, this really vulnerable belief that we don't think anyone will ever stay or anyone will ever love us enough to not abandonment. us. I think the reason we don't want to admit that is because we think that that says something about us. And we also are worried that what if we continue to be proven right? What if we admit this to someone, maybe a friend or a partner, whoever it may be, and they still leave? The thing is, something I really want to make quite clear, a fear of abandonment has nothing to do with your quality and beauty as a human or the kind of depth of your soul of what you bring to other people.
你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地去当一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖姆斯。我们在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。
really has no correlation with how people choose to treat you or have treated you in the past. Often I think if we've experienced a number of really painful events or instances of withdrawal or where someone we thought would love us forever has abandoned us, we convince ourselves that we must be the common denominator, that there is something that we are doing wrong. And that can become like we've explored a bit of a self-fulfilling prophecy whereby the behaviors we adopt to seemingly protect us or the ones that we use as defense mechanisms have an opposite effect of actually further removing us from situations in which someone could maybe prove you wrong. A fear of abandonment in that way is so subconscious. And so it's going to
我认为我们中的很多人都在以非常隐蔽的方式与此作斗争，这通常是因为我真的认为我们不想承认这种极其脆弱的不安全感，这种极其脆弱的信念：我们认为永远不会有人留下来，或者永远不会有人足够爱我们而不会抛弃我们。我想我们不想承认这一点的原因，是因为我们觉得这说明了我们自身有什么问题。而且我们也担心，万一我们不断被证明是对的呢？万一我们向某人承认这一点（也许是朋友或伴侣，无论是谁），而他们还是离开了呢？问题是，我真的很想明确的一点是，对被抛弃的恐惧与你作为一个人的人品和美德，或者你的灵魂深度以及你能带给别人的东西没有任何关系。
continue to operate unless we, A, acknowledge it and B really get to the root cause or address this pattern so that we don't see that typical repeated time. timeline in relationships. This cycle, this timeline, it's characterized by a few major things, right, that inability to fully commit the heightened emotions and anxiety as the relationship becomes more serious. Sometimes we have that emotional baiting or testing and finally self-sabotage or withdrawal. There was this really good example that I found, which I think sums this up really well. And I think a typical relationship of involving someone with abandonment issues might go through some of the following stages. So you start off in the early days. At this point,
这真的与别人选择如何对待你或过去如何对待你没有任何关联。通常我认为，如果我们经历过许多非常痛苦的事件、疏离的时刻，或者某个我们以为会永远爱我们的人抛弃了我们，我们就会说服自己，我们一定是那个共同的分母，一定是我们有什么地方做错了。这就可能变成我们刚才探讨过的那种自我实现的预言：我们为了表面上保护自己而采取的行为，或者我们用作防御机制的行为，反而产生了相反的效果，使我们进一步远离了那些本可以向你证明你是错的情境。这种对被抛弃的恐惧是如此潜意识。因此它会
it's all really fun. You feel really safe. You're not really emotionally invested yet. So you kind of continue to live your life whilst also really enjoying time with them. I think at this point, we're not worried about abandonment. We're not really in that mind frame yet. Then we have the honeymoon phase. And this is where you choose to commit. You kind of maybe overlook some of your anxiety, you overlook some of the red flags, you suppress some of those emotional wounds because you feel embarrassed by them, you don't want to admit them to your new partner, your new boyfriend or girlfriend, and you do in some ways feel really secure because this person has offered you exclusivity or commitment and you're not yet so emotionally invested that those fears are starting
继续发挥作用，除非我们：A，承认它；B，真正找到根源或解决这个模式，这样我们就不会在关系中看到那种典型的、重复的时间线。这个循环、这个时间线，其特征是几个主要方面，对吧？无法完全承诺，随着关系变得更加严肃而产生的加剧的情绪和焦虑。有时我们会进行情感试探或测试，最后是自我破坏或疏离。我找到了一个非常好的例子，我认为这很好地总结了这一点。而且我认为一个涉及有被抛弃情结的典型恋情可能会经历以下几个阶段。所以你在早期就开始了。在这个时候，
to really bubble up. And then as you become partners, as things get more serious, things get in the way. You know, relationships are sometimes quite hard. People have bad days. Work gets really annoying. You have to cancel plans. You worry about money. And something really small might occur. And an example of this is, for example, an unanswered text message or an unreturned phone call. To most people, I think that this is really normal, right? They might find a different reason. They might give themselves a rational explanation for why this is happening. They're at work, their phone's dead, they just haven't gotten around to replying to me, they're busy. But if you're someone who already has that initial anxiety or bias that this person is going to leave you,
一切都很有趣。你感到非常安全。你还没有真正投入感情。所以你一边继续过着自己的生活，一边真的很享受和他们在一起的时光。我想此时此刻，我们并不担心被抛弃。我们还没有进入那种心态。然后我们迎来了蜜月期。在这里，你选择做出承诺。你可能忽略了自己的一些焦虑，忽略了一些危险信号，压抑了那些情感创伤，因为你对它们感到尴尬，不想向你的新伴侣、新男友或女朋友承认，而且你在某种程度上确实感到很有安全感，因为这个人给了你排他性或承诺，而你还没有投入到那种会让恐惧开始真正涌上心头的程度。然后，随着你们成为伴侣，随着事情变得更加严肃，各种事情就会横亘在中间。你知道，恋爱有时挺艰难的。人们会有糟糕的日子。工作变得很烦人。你不得不取消计划。你为钱操心。而一些非常小的事情可能就会发生。这其中的一个例子，比如，一条没有回复的短信或一个没有回电的电话。对大多数人来说，我认为这真的很正常，对吧？他们可能会找到别的原因。他们可能会为发生这种事给自己一个合理的解释：他们在工作，手机没电了，只是还没顾得上回复我，他们很忙。但如果你是一个内心已经带着这种最初焦虑或偏见——即这个人会离开你——的人，
you're probably really going to battle really hard internally about how to respond. Because to you, in your state of hypervigilance, that is a really big sign that they might be going to leave you. That is a sign that they're pulling away. And although quite rationally and objectively, someone else might look, look at that and say, well, that's ridiculous. You have this fear response that's become deeply ingrained. So some people handle that by becoming really clingy, really insistent and demanding, and other people also just withdraw at that first sign of difficulty or what they interpret to be a sign that they're about to be left or broken up with. They make the first move,
你内心可能就要为如何回应进行一场非常激烈的斗争。因为对你而言，在你高度警惕的状态下，这是一个巨大的信号，预示着他们可能要离开你了。这是一个他们在疏离的信号。尽管非常理性和客观地看，别人可能会看着这件事说，这太荒谬了，但你却有一种已经根深蒂固的恐惧反应。因此，有些人通过变得非常黏人、非常坚持和苛求来应对，而另一些人则在遇到困难的第一迹象时，或者在他们解读为即将被抛弃或分手的信号时选择退缩。他们抢先采取行动，
but they're making the first move with false information, with information that is coming from subjective bias or a place of fear. So how do we prevent our fear of abandonment from doing this, from really interrupting these healthy, beautiful connections? I'm going to give you a few tips, both from personal experience and then some more clinical advice that, you know, a therapist or a psychologist might give you. Number one, and I think this is something everyone listening is already doing, but you kind of need to shake hands with who you are at this point and where you're at, and acknowledge that this is something that you're dealing with. I think you need to approach it really objectively, so no self-pity.
但他们采取行动依据的是错误的信息，是源于主观偏见或恐惧的信息。那么，我们该如何防止对被抛弃的恐惧这样做，防止它真正打断这些健康、美好的连接呢？我将给出一些建议，既有我个人的经验，也有一些治疗师或心理学家会给你的临床建议。第一点，我认为这也是每个在听的听众已经在做的事，但你需要与此时此刻的自己以及你所处的现状握手言和，承认这是你正在应对的事情。我认为你需要非常客观地对待它，不要自我同情。
Try not to fear what this means or look for blame or back in the past for something you could change. Sadly, that's one of the realities of time. We can't change what brought us here. However, I do believe in our ability to control how we interpret and deal with our fear. So if you have acknowledged that you may be dealing with this fear of abandonment, you've acknowledged that or looked back at past relationships and said, oh my God, I can clearly see now where I have self-sabotaged or where I have been avoidant or where I have been forning or people pleasing, that is really valuable information and that is information that can only help you be better. So that first thing, acknowledge that this is where you're at and then examine why you believe this. where did you learn this belief? Where did you learn this idea that everyone who loves you will leave? So examining like the origin story, that's often a technique used in psychotherapy where it is really
尽量不要害怕这意味着什么，也不要寻找责备，或者回到过去寻找你可以改变的东西。可悲的是，这就是时间的现实之一。我们无法改变把我们带到这里的过去。然而，我相信我们有能力控制自己如何解读和处理恐惧。因此，如果你已经承认自己可能正在应对这种对被抛弃的恐惧，你已经承认了这一点，或者回顾了过去的恋爱关系，并说：“天哪，我现在可以清楚地看到我在哪里进行了自我破坏，在哪里表现得回避，或者在哪里迎合、讨好他人”，这真的是非常宝贵的信息，这些信息只会帮助你变得更好。所以第一点，承认这就是你的现状，然后检查你为什么会有这种信念。你在哪里学到这种信念的？你在哪里学到“每个爱你的人都会离开”这种想法的？所以要追溯起源，这通常是心理治疗中常用的一种技术，即通过讨论我们当前的经历并追溯它们的起源，以及它们如何仍在影响你当前的生活，这会非常有用。也许是你目睹了父母之间一场极其糟糕的离婚，这教会了你爱情无法持久；或者你发现你的伴侣出轨了，现在你再也无法信任别人了。你如此害怕这种被抛弃。无论是什么，我想让你意识到的是，这不是你的错。你没有选择那段经历，它也并不能说明你有什么问题。更重要的是，你来决定接下来要去哪里。我们通过识别是什么、何时以及什么触发了这种反应来做到这一点。在心理学中，触发点本质上是事件、
useful to talk through our current experiences and trace them back to where they may have began and how they're still influencing what is currently happening in your life. Maybe it was you witnessed a really terrible divorce between your parents and that's taught you that love does not last or you found out that your partner was cheating and now you can't trust people anymore. You're so fearful of this abandonment. Whatever it is, what I want you to realize is that it is not your fault. You did not choose that experience and it doesn't say anything about you either. And more importantly, you get to decide where you go to next. And we do this by identifying why, when, and what triggers this reaction. In psychology, triggers are essentially events,
情境、环境中的事物，它们会引发强烈或意料之外的情绪反应。因此，当我们谈论对被抛弃的恐惧时，一个常见的情况正如我们之前所说，可能是伴侣不回复你的消息，或者要求独处的时间。之所以会触发他们会离开你的这种焦虑，是因为你的大脑正在根据过去的经验寻找作为警告信号的模式，并告诉你要做出某种反应。这就是为什么这件事所谓的“触发”了你，让你产生了这种意料之外的反应，产生了这种想要逃跑或者把这个人紧紧拉住并表现得很黏人的渴望。
situations, things in the environment that elicit a really intense or unexpected emotional response. So when we're talking about a fear of abandonment, one that is common is, as we spoke about before, a partner maybe not replying to your messages, or perhaps asking for a lone time. So the reason that this triggers this anxiety around them leaving you is because your brain is searching for patterns that serve as warning signs based on past experiences and is telling you to react in a certain way. That is why this thing has so-called triggered you to have this really unexpected response, this perhaps desire to run away or to pull this person in really closely and be really needy.
那一刻，你真的需要停下来、暂停、感受，然后进行理性思考。这真的是发生的事情吗？这个人真的给我任何其他迹象表明他们是这种感受、他们要离开我吗？然后请求保证。与其用情感试探来测试你的伴侣，不如通过脆弱和诚实来测试他们，我会这么说。也许“测试”不是正确的词，但我认为请求
in that moment you really need to stop, pause, feel, and then rationalise. Is this really what's happening? Has this person really given me any other indicator that this is how they're feeling that they are going to leave me? And then ask for reassurance. Instead of testing your partner with emotional baiting, test them, I would say, through vulnerability and honesty. And maybe test isn't the right word, but I think asking,
明确并追求开放的沟通，看看你的伴侣如何回应，这比退缩、挑起争端或把他们推开，更能告诉你关于你们关系的未来或他们是否会离开你的更多信息。坐下来谈谈，说：“嘿，当你白天不回消息时，我真的很焦虑。你能偶尔跟我报个平安吗？”也许出于某种原因他们做不到。然后他们会告诉你原因。问题是，他们的理由会比你在脑子里编造的理由合理得多，也真实得多。所以我认为告诉他们非常重要，告诉他们你的感受。其次，对被抛弃的恐惧往往会导致自我抛弃。
for clarity and pursuing open communication, seeing how you're a partner responds to that is going to tell you a whole lot more about the future of your relationship or whether they're going to leave you than withdrawing or starting a fight or pushing them away. Just have a sit down and say, hey, it makes me really anxious when you don't reply during the day. Can you just check in with me every now and again? And maybe they can't do that for some reason. And they tell you why. And the thing is it's that their reason it's going to be much more valid and much more real than the one that you're probably making up in your head. So I think it's really important to just tell them, tell them how you're feeling. Secondly, often a fear of abandonment can result in self-abandonment.
当你害怕被抛弃或解雇时，你会不惜一切代价让关系运转下去，不惜任何代价，即使这个人对你不好。因此，我们有时会真正忽视自己的身体、心理、情感、社交、精神需求。当你遇到某人时，如果你发现自己有被抛弃情结，也许你会停止照顾自己，停止做那些能给你带来快乐、帮你过上平衡生活的事情，因为你把他们放在首位，确保自己没有给他们任何退缩的理由。所以一些例子比如：你不再花时间陪朋友，即使他们并没有要求你这样做；你为了他们放弃了你的爱好或你的空闲时间；你忽视了锻炼、睡眠或自我护理这些事情。
When you are afraid of being left or dismissed, you'll kind of do anything to make the relationship work, no matter the cost, even if this person is bad for you. as a result we can sometimes really neglect our own physical, mental, emotional, social, spiritual needs. When you meet someone, if you find you have abandonment issues, maybe you will stop taking care of yourself and doing the things that bring you joy and help you live to balance life because you are prioritizing them and making sure that you're not giving them any reason to back away. So some examples are you stop spending time with your friends, even if they're, they're not asking you to do that, you give up on your hobbies or your free time for them, you neglect things like working out or your sleep or your self-care practices.
但关键在于，当你停止照顾自己或者进行我们所说的自我抛弃时，这只会增加你这段关系的赌注。这会让你对关系一旦结束可能发生的事情感到更加不安全，因为如果你为了维持这种连接而牺牲了一切，你就没有任何可以依靠的你所关心的事情了。所以我想说，尽量不要让一个人或一段新的火花压倒你在个人层面上认为重要的东西。
Here's the thing, though, when you stop taking care of yourself or you engage in what we call self-abandonment, that really just increases the stakes of your relationship. And it makes you feel more insecure about what might happen if the relationship were to end, because you have nothing you care about to fall back on if you've sacrificed it all, for maintaining this connection. So I would say, try not to let a person or a new spark overwhelm what's important to you on an individual level.
做出真正的刻意努力去维持你热爱的生活。我认为除此之外，这也意味着你将有更少的时间去担心他们可能会想什么，或者去对你的关系以及所有可能让你害怕或担忧的事情进行不必要的胡思乱想。我认为对自己所拥有的关系感到安全，真的能让你对与他人建立的纽带和连接感到更加安全。
Make a really deliberate effort to maintain the life that you love. I think additionally, this also means that you just have less time to worry about what they might be thinking or to ruminate unnecessarily on your relationship and all the things that might be scary or worrying you. I think feeling secure in the relationship you have with yourself really allows you to feel more secure in the bonds and the connections that you have with others.
第三，记住你的感觉不等于现实。它们只是感觉。你的恐惧只是你的大脑试图通过逃避你在过去经历过的痛苦来帮助你。但是你的大脑、你的心智无法预测未来。它只是在充当向导。所以虽然你可能会害怕，你现在可能会感受到很多恐惧，但要通过改变叙事和质疑证据来挑战那些“没有人会永远爱你”的负面信念。这种感觉从何而来？为什么我会这么想？为什么我认为他们不爱我？他们说过什么暗示了这一点吗？别人说过吗？你亲眼看到了吗？如果没有，试着意识到在它真正发生之前，它并不是一个问题。我知道要顺应那种不确定感和不了解现实的滋味很难。但我总是说，最好是看看会发生什么，
Thirdly, remember that your feelings are not reality. They are just feelings. Your fear is just your mind trying to help you out by avoiding a pain you've experienced in the past. But your brain, your mind, it can't predict the future. It's just serving as a guide. So although you might be scared, you might feel a lot of fear right now. Challenge those negative beliefs that no one will ever love you. Challenge that belief that everyone will leave you by changing the narrative and questioning the evidence. Where is that feeling coming from? Why do I think this? Why do I think they don't love me? Have they told me something that has told me this? Has someone else told me? Have you seen it? If not, try and realize that it's not a problem until it is. And I know it's hard to lean into that discomfort. it and the reality of not knowing. But what I always say is that it's better to see what happens
总好过在关系有机会证明你是错的或展开它的剧情之前，因为选择退缩而留下一堆“如果……会怎样”的遗憾。我认为现实是，无论你如何试图测试他人、练习回避或拼命抓紧他们，你都无法完全避免偶尔受到伤害。这其实只是旅程的一部分。但我认为你真的需要有时让生活给你一些惊喜，并知道无论发生什么，你都尽力了，你冒险了，你让自己变得脆弱了，你感受到了恐惧，但还是去做了。我认为每一次这都非常值得。最后，我再给你一个建议，因为这对我真的很有帮助。那就是过度沟通。通常你对
than to be left with the what if of pulling away before the relationship has had a chance to prove you wrong or really live out its storyline. I think the reality is that you can't avoid being hurt every now and again no matter how much you might try and test people or practice avoidance or cling on to them for dear life. It's kind of just part of the journey. But I think you really need to let life surprise you sometimes and know that whatever happens, you gave it your best, you took a chance, you let yourself be vulnerable, and you felt the fear and did it anyways. And I think that is so worth it every single time. Finally, I'm going to give you one more tip because this is something that has really helped me. That is to over communicate. Often your perception
某个局势、某个事件或者你的伴侣或朋友所做的事情的感知，会被你自己的认知偏见和焦虑所严重干扰。因此，过度沟通你的需求，告诉人们你的感受、你是如何解读这个局势的，真的非常非常重要。很显然，你不需要在第一次约会时就直接跳到你过去的创伤，因为我们知道，那其实是你通过过度分享而被激活的对被抛弃的恐惧。但你应该做的是，随着时间的推移，坦诚地展现为什么你可能会对某种特定情况做出特定反应，为什么你可能比一般人需要更多的安抚，以及你的伴侣能用什么方式让你感到更有安全感。如果他们是个好人，他们会对之做出回应。我见过这种情况发生。这很美好。他们会理解，
of a situation or an event or something your partner or a friend has done is going to be really disturbed by your own cognitive biases and anxiety. And so over-communicating what you need, telling people how you feel, how you interpreted a situation is really, really important. And obviously, you don't need to jump right into your past trauma on the first state, because we know that that is really your fear of abandonment being activated by oversharing. But what you should do is really reveal with time perhaps why you might react in a certain way, why you maybe need a little bit more reassurance than the average person, ways that your partner can make you feel safer. And if they're a good person, they'll respond to that. I've seen it happen. It's beautiful. They'll understand,
并且他们真的会希望给你那种安全感。如果你一直在质疑这些，我真的希望这能对你有所帮助。我只想说，心理治疗对于整合可能表现为对被抛弃恐惧的过去创伤能起到巨大的作用。我认为心理治疗太棒了，因为有一个第三方介入，他们可以作为局外人、作为没有偏见的人，真正发挥巨大价值，打断那种负面且有害的信念或假设的模式。所以这绝对是另一件值得考虑的事情。但作为一个曾经处理过这个问题，并在目前的关系中对此进行过非常坦诚讨论的人，我现在告诉你，事情真的会变得容易得多，并且一定会有这样一个人
and they'll really want to give you that sense of security and safety. I really hope that this has helped you if you've been questioning this. There is also, I'm just going to say it so much that therapy can do for integrating past trauma that might be manifesting in a fear of abandonment. I think that therapy is amazing because there is a third party there who can really be so valuable and interrupt that pattern of negative and harmful beliefs or assumptions as someone who is not involved, as someone who is unbiased. So definitely something else to think about. But as someone who has dealt with this previously and has had really open discussions about this in my current relationship. I'm telling you now it does get a lot easier and there is someone
在外面，他会留下来，会在半路与你相遇，会证明持续的爱与陪伴确实存在。所以我希望这是一个非常坚实、有用且令人宽慰的提醒，为这一集画上句号。我想这就是我们所有的全部时间了，但我真的希望你喜欢这一期。这是一个有点科学性、有点像坐过山车，但也极其有价值的一期。我认为如果你未来再次感到焦虑或担心这些事情，我希望人们可以重新听听这一集。
out there who will stay, who will meet you in the middle, who will kind of prove that consistent love and companionship does exist. So I hope that that is a really solid, helpful, comforting reminder to finish off this episode. I think that that is all we have time for, but I really do hope that you enjoyed. It was a bit of a scientific one, a little bit of a roller coaster, but also so valuable. I think that this is something that I hope people can come back to if you're anxious or worried about these things, perhaps again in the future.
一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你收听的任何地方留下五星好评。如果你想看幕后花絮或提出节目建议，请去Instagram关注@That Psychology Podcast，如果你只想看更多个人内容，可以关注@Gemma Spegg。
As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening. Go and follow us at That Psychology Podcast on Instagram if you want to see behind the scenes or have an episode suggestion, and you can follow me at Gemma Spegg if you just want to see more personal content.
我们还有一个Patreon。它链接在节目简介中。做这个播客需要很多工作，我真的很感激所有的支持。如果你确实从这些节目中获得了价值，并且你还没有为此付费、捐款或以其他方式表示支持，如果你觉得内心有所触动，这是一个帮助我的小方法。非常感谢你收听这一集，我们下周将带着另一集回归。2%。
We also have a Patreon. It's linked in the episode description. It's a lot of work doing this podcast, and I really do appreciate all the support. If you do get value from these episodes and you're not already paying for it or contributing or showing your support in other ways, it's just a small way to help me out if you feel called to do so. So thank you so much for tuning into this episode, and we will be back next week with another one. 2%.
这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯顿。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。
That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
收听《2%》。名字是T-W-O-P-e-r-s-e-n-t，可在I-Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和来说是一个巨大的时刻。84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·杰克，我是亚历克斯·英格利希。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO. Percent on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a Podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay and I'm Alex English.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、喜剧同仁和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代。那是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说更重要了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
你正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Keog Game. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused. to fathering twins. But the pregnancy
生下了一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕
appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. I'm
似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。我是
Stephanie Young. This is Love Traft. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《陷入爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是真人。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。